vous avez eu une grande histoire c'est
quoi votre plus grande histoire d'amour
deux mois il a dit non non non maintenir
longtemps avec quelqu'un non la plus
grande c'est quatre ans entre web et
vous est ce que vous l'avez tromper oui
plus grande c'est 4 tandis que vous avez
trompé la personne oui non merci mais
comme les eliane biais de la vie est
trop court
[Applaudissements]
la vie est trop mon père où les
abonnements
oui oui en date est matthieu où ça vous
dérange vous non pas du tout je trouve
ça très excitant exaltant et formidable
qui est plein de conquête avant contrats
vers la terre pour moi aussi à bas bruit
est sorti avec jean michel maire alors
quand même pas faux cul non quand même
pas vous christine mois avant vers des
galas chômage en fait
watch the air ou bouaké ce cas non non
je sais pas c'était jean michel maire ou
quoi non mais avant après moi le déluge
en quoi oui à la maison voir et moi le
déluge
howell conant ça s'en va ça se passe
voilà voilà la vrai savon moi rien à
cirer après moi rien non c'est pas vous
n'aurez alors savoir le mécénat qui dit
tu crois que je les ai comptés battez
pas bien à moi justement je veux le
savoir
c'est justement ce qu'il est désiré
c'est qu'il a beaucoup plu et ça me
plaît encore plus oui parle de ça elle a
l'air au bout du bout on dirait que les
mises au tableau en train de faire une
division avec des guillemets avec une
décimale fouich a pas envie d'en parler
d'accord